this morning welcome to the
europe day eu careers
careers at the european institutions
event today
as you might know um on the 7th of may
for the first time since these two years
the european institutions are opening
their doors again physically in brussels
strasbourg and luxembourg
we were thinking a lot what we should do
today
in order to to talk to as many of you as
possible so that's why we came to that
idea that we would like to talk to you
online today and we organize this online
event
when i say we it's the european personal
selection office epso and the european
commission
and with that i come to the introduction
of our guests today as well
on my left um there is dornitza
vancouver who is the deputy head of unit
of dg hr's corporate internal
communication unit
and on my right is my colleague kun
hendricks we both work
at apsu
in the external communication team
we are doing lots of outreach we are
trying to communicate to everyone
interested about eu careers and my name
is jutahinak i think i didn't say that
yet
so um i think now we have more people
who joined in um i think we can very
very slowly start
our conversation this morning is going
to be more or less 30
minutes and i would like to
go already with my first question
probably tukun um as an introduction
cohen
we were talking about our team in the
european personal selection office where
we both work could you please tell us a
bit more about uh how we are selecting
what we are doing what episode is about
all right indeed so the european
personnel selection office
does exactly what it says it selects
staff for all eu institutions now when i
say all eu institutions there's a family
of institutions and bodies that you can
work in
and i'm sure you know several of them
i'm sure you know the european
parliament
uh i guess you are familiar with the
council of the european union and then
there's of course the european
commission
then we also have two courts there's the
european court of auditors and the
european court of justice where you can
work
then we have the european external
action service that is the body that
runs all the european embassies we call
them the delegations outside of the
european union
then we have two committees there is the
economic and social committee and
there's the committee of the regions
where you can work
then there's also the european ombudsman
and the european data protection
supervisor so those are the ten
institutions where you can work
and all together these institutions
employ about 40 000 staff
of which roughly 30 000 work for the
commission alone so the commission is by
far the largest institution
second would be the parliament with
about three to four thousand staff and
then you've got the other institutions
that are a bit smaller in size
the headquarters of these institutions
are based in brussels and luxembourg
apart from one the ombudsman is based in
strasbourg
so chances are that whenever you join us
you start your career in brussels or
luxembourg because that is where about
eighty percent of all staff works
the remaining twenty percent works in
other cities outside brussels or
luxembourg we have
what we call representations in each
member states capital
we have joint research centers these are
european research centers in a number of
member states
we have also a network of agencies all
over the eu we have different agencies
working for the eu
and then we have these delegations which
i mentioned up front those are the
bodies outside of the of the european
union that have the link with the
countries outside of the eu
so this is basically where you can end
up working this is the whole family that
we select staff for that's great that
gives us the scope but i'm being a bit
more specific zarnitza can you tell us a
bit because you just mentioned that the
commission is the biggest institution
isn't it
um can you tell us a bit about the
commission's role how it works
what are the challenges at the moment
sure of course uh hello from my part two
the european commission um
is
proposing clause
uh running programs this is the
executive body of the european
institutions of course all these in
service of the european uh citizens uh
of course when we are proposing these
laws all this is done on the basis of
very
wide consultations with different
stakeholders
from national parliament
to employers group
or
trade unions or
other
different organizations and to citizens
indeed
we are also
running the new budget
making sure that this european
laws when they are
adopted by the member states in the
council and by the european parliament
uh then then the member states are
really implementing them correctly and
we are of course uh supporting uh
different uh the
supporting uh the distribution of
international aid because the european
union you may know is one of the biggest
donor in the in the world um i can give
you some example for example um
already
this week the the european commission
launched the european health data space
which is something that will
boost the significantly uh the whale the
way that health care is provided in
europe and it will give the possibility
uh to european citizens to control and
to
to use their
health in their own countries but also
in the other member states for example
this is one of the
legislation where the proposal comes
after the consultation with a wide
variety of stakeholders including
after an online consultation with
citizens
another
example that i'm sure many of
our viewers
are
familiar with is the erasmus program
which is run by the european commission
and that and which since its creations
have
uh helped
over
3 millions students
to participate in this exchange program
uh of course uh you you mentioned that
we are 33 000 indeed we are
too many but uh this diversity
um
this this number is not so huge this is
this number is not exceeding the number
of
civil servants in the white in the
municipality in one in the big cities in
europe
and what is maybe interesting is that we
are as diverse and as
from point of view of backgrounds and
as the society we are serving so if you
are interested
we are really touching in a very wide
variety of policies working on wide
variety of policies so if you're
interested don't hesitate to apply for
working permission
i heard your two words apply and variety
at the very end what are the contracts
what are the variety of contracts you
can tell us about [ __ ] yeah indeed so if
you want to work with us we have as you
say different contracts on offer the
biggest group of staff here is what we
call a civil servant or an eu official
and these are people with a contract for
life reading so you enter as a civil
servant and you can make your whole
career
by staying with us until you retire as
an eu official
apart from that
group of civil servants we also have
what we call contract agents and as the
word it says these people have a
contract limited in time
usually that's a contract of about three
years which can be renewed once so up to
six years you can work under the statute
of a contact agent with us
then we also have what we call temporary
agents temporary agents work usually in
agencies you heard me tell about these
different agencies all over the eu there
you'll find a lot of temporary agents
people with a degree and specific
work experience in a specific field and
they can work in these different
agencies and bodies as a temporary agent
then we also have what we call second
national experts second national experts
are
civil servants in their home country
and they are second to the eu and they
come and work with us for a number of
years and share their knowledge and
expertise with us while they work with
us here
and then there's a very nice category of
staff which are the trainees every
single eu institution
offers the opportunity to become a tree
trainee with them and that's a nice
opportunity to to find out about the
internal cuisine of
of the institutions the commission for
instance runs the biggest traineeship in
the world
they welcome 18 to 1900 trainees a year
into two shifts of five months one
traineeship starting in march and one
starting in october and that's really a
nice way to get to know the eu
institution from inside out
sounds great you mentioned here
permanent officials and i think we need
some more information to that zornitza
so um permanent officials when they are
hired do they remain in the same
job or their professional life or
is it there something
more exciting about them
thanks very much for this question
because uh
it may be not very clear for everybody
but the answer is definitely no as a
matter of fact once you get into the
european commission uh you're even
encouraged after five years in the same
position to move to another position to
move on another um
in in another department let's say or
within the same department but doing uh
some something else and of course this
is possible because there is a lot of
learning opportunities inside so you can
really have the possibility
if you enter for example as a policy
officer
and you are dealing with some particular
policy but then you decide that you want
to be uh to deal with the communication
you can follow for example the internal
uh training uh that exists that we have
put in place and um after concluding a
good number of
courses uh you you can then
have the reassurance first yourself but
then you have also the the possibility
to apply for jobs related to
communication and this is just one of
the many examples
another thing is that
for example
you can enter as
assistant and i'm sure we'll tell you a
little bit more about this
but then you can follow some kind of we
call this certification
and then you can move and became an
administrator so you have the
possibility uh to move horizontally
but also vertically because of course
you you have the possibility to grow in
the job and to
uh be first the probably the test policy
officer and then became maybe team
leader um deputy head of unit head of
unit director director general so you
have this uh of course this possibility
and there is a third thing that may be
interesting for you that it is not uh
when you start working for example in
brussels uh you're not obliged to stay
all your life for your career in
brussels you have quite a lot of
possibility to move
uh to move for example in luxembourg to
move in italy in israel where it's the
biggest third biggest site
[Music]
of the european commission but also in
the
representations in the member states and
you can also apply for a work in the
delegations around the world so you have
plenty of possibility for this kind of
professional and even physical mobility
and not to mention that you can also if
you start in the commission to move and
work for the parliament on a later stage
come back to the commission and
this is also a possibility that exists
thank you there's plenty of environments
as we can hear
um i'm turning to you and i would like
to
to ask you to give some examples on the
profiles because i think there's a huge
variety geographically
also with the different priorities
challenges we have at the moment how
about the profiles how does it reflect
there what we are looking for that is a
good point you mentioned there so
i'm sure you you can think of some
profiles that we need in the eu
institutions here of course we need many
lawyers right because we produce
legislation as it's already mentioned
we need many economists because we are
an economic union
we need lots of linguists you know we
need translators and interpreters
because we communicate in 24 official
evil languages so those are big groups
of staff if you like now apart from
these
we basically need people with any given
background we need specialists in i.t
in finance in accounting we need web
designers we need scientists we need
psychologists we need biologists we need
journalists
we need drivers we need secretaries i
mean i can go on there is really a job
for anyone with any background or degree
that's really the message i want to give
if you think about
working for the eu as a project if you
want to give something back to society
if you want to help promote the eu
project well this is the place to be
because here you work on a supra
national level on all of these different
topics and policies and you really help
to shape europe together
so i would only say come here and join
us
but before you all jump off and go and
apply
i think we should hear a little bit
about what is really like to work at the
commission zone it's like could you give
us kind of a few insight how does it
look like if someone starts a career at
the commission how is it as an employer
let's say
yes of course when you
enter the commission of course the first
thing that uh and i'm sure you're
looking for is an interesting job and a
job with a strong purpose and that's
saying it's really um
very noble work
on my humble opinion
to work in service of
all our
european uh citizens so uh you have
this really opportunity for very
interesting and well from time to time
challenging
job uh that touch that can touch on
wide variety on policies
you have plenty opportunity for training
we are really offering a different kind
of opportunity not only
to learn
many languages
this is something that is
for me quite an added value but to learn
new skills new competencies that will
give you also the opportunity uh for
this mobility that we were uh talking uh
a little bit earlier which gives of
course the opportunity to try several
several areas of work throughout your
career
of course i mentioned it before um
we need to serve a very diverse
society so we have to
reflect that this society so and of
course
what you meet in the european uh
institutions and especially in the
commission is this a vibrant inter
multicultural
community of people which i would say
it's very enriching and
very pleasant to work
with and in
and
of course something that is very
important at least for me and for my
colleagues that
our institution is offering also
is caring a lot about the workplace
balance
and
we are offering flexible working
conditions
possibility to work
remotely from coma for a certain period
of time during the week
so
indeed we care about the uh the
well-being of our staff
our workplace is environment friendly i
mean we are preaching what we are
suggesting and proposing to to the
member states for example
um
a month ago
the college commissioner adopted the
decision but the commission
will become a climate neutral by 2030
which is basically uh 20 years earlier
than the target set for the entire
european union and of course this means
greener buildings fewer
fewer buildings for the commission uh
buildings that are
[Music]
using renewable energy solar panels
but also encouraging
staff to use more public transport
to walk more to cycle more not only
because it's also good for their health
but also because it's good for the
nature
i'm not even mentioning that
we're reducing the use of paper
even trying to where possible instead of
traveling
to
use video conferences and to use a
greener travel and i can go on and go on
as much as possible
quite a lot
say quite a lot of other things
but maybe uh something that may be
interesting for you too is uh of course
because uh most of our colleagues and uh
most of you if you uh became
you
come and join us you need to to leave
your
country your home country and uh came
either here or in in luxembourg or
somewhere in the other side so we are
also offering a quite attractive
financial package with the good health
insurance uh with the good the passion
scheme and
for those who have kids also european
schools
that
where your kids can continue
study on their native language and learn
more languages
and of course we are proud to be
equal opportunity employer and we
promote the diversity
thank you so much it's a lot isn't it so
i hope i hope many of our viewers would
like to be selected and that's the word
uh what i would like to give to kuhn now
how is app selecting the staff
indeed that's the big question right so
how to join us how can you become one of
our staff members here at the eu
institutions
let me say a word first on how to become
a civil servant an eu official
if you want to become an eo official you
need to take part in a selection
procedure of course which we call a
competition or a concur in french
and everything starts on our website you
see it behind us onitsa there eu
careers.eu that's where you will find a
list of current and upcoming
opportunities so first thing to do is to
find a competition which matches your
profile
once you found one
you apply and you will be invited to a
series of tests now we offer
competitions on different levels
and for different fields we have
competitions on graduate level
graduate level meaning you need a
university degree to be able to be
eligible to be able to apply
and you would if you are successful
enter the category of administrators so
lisa mentioned these administrators
early wrong
we also have competitions on an
executive level a non-graduate level
which would lead to a career as an
assistant so those are the two career
paths that we offer graduates are
administered administrators and
non-graduates are assistants
we run competitions year round for both
of these categories of staff
then we have the difference between
competitions where you do need a certain
year a certain number of years of
experience in a field
and we have competitions where we do not
ask for any work experience
to give you an example
soon in june
we will publish a competition for
specialists in the field of space
and for specialists in defense and these
are people who are highly specialized we
need people with uh at least six years
of experience in the field of space and
defense that's just to give you an
example of an upcoming competition as i
said you'll find a list
on the website and this list is of
course updated regularly
next year we will publish again
opportunities for people without work
experience so for entry level
graduates
administrators at level 85 that's the
entry level for young graduates so
that's for 2023
now how does such a competition look
like it will have always several stages
as i said everything starts with an
application on the website you have to
apply
within a given application period and
once you have applied you will be
invited to a series of tests
the first round of testing will always
be
a reasoning skills test we want to see
how good you are at verbal reasoning
numerical reasoning and abstract
reasoning
if you pass that stage
and if you take part in a specialist
competition you know a competition where
we require a number of years of
experience in the field
we will of course test your competency
in that field and then for each
competition the last stage would be what
we call an assessment center and in this
assessment center we test a number of
general competencies
such as can you communicate easily
orally and in writing can you work in
teams can you analyze problems can you
prioritize your work these kind of
things
we test these competencies through a
number of tests usually two tests one of
which can be a case study which is a
written exercise
it can be an oral presentation you have
to do
and there will always be of course an
interview with the selection board
you can sit all these tests remotely you
don't have to travel you don't have to
come to brussels or luxembourg to sit
these tests you can do them online
remotely from a computer from your home
to make your life easy
once you are successful in a competition
you are a laureate or a successful
candidate and these people are the ones
that are then recruited
by these different institutions that i
mentioned earlier on
is the same for contract agents
for contract agents it's a bit different
it's good that you mentioned this um you
heard me say that we have this this
category of staff that has a contract
limited in time now on our website you
will find a list of about 15 different
profiles under this contract agent study
we have people
in the profile of communication that we
need in hr in finance in law in project
management there are different profiles
on offer
and you can actually register for any of
these profiles even more than one
as of today these registration periods
have no deadline so you can always
register for one or more of these
profiles
that's quite interesting because
actually what you can do is you can
register for these profiles
and when an institution needs these
needs to fill vacancies in these
profiles
they will scan the list of people
registered
and they will pre-select a number of
interesting profiles to fill that
vacancy
these people will be sent to exo and we
will test these people
we will test their reasoning skills
same thing verbal numerical and abstract
reasoning
and we will test their competency in the
field of the profile if they are
successful they can be hired and offered
a contract
great thank you so much for all insights
and explanations so far and as i can see
we are actually meeting towards the end
so if there's only something else you
would like to tell our viewers
who are interested in you careers we
have still a few minutes yes thanks uh
maybe three things one of the things is
if you are interested
in european policies but you are not
completely convinced that you want to
work for the european commission i would
strongly invite you to apply first for a
traineeship which will give you a quite
a good overview
what is it like to work for the
commission
second if you want to learn more about
what the commission is doing
i would invite you to go on our website
which is easy europa
dot europa dot eu
and where you can also find
quite a lot of information about
the activities that are
running throughout the weekend um
here in brussels uh as you mentioned uh
our doors are open uh
uh for uh
for
those who are interested not only
brussels but in luxembourg
in strasbourg in the member states
mainly on the 9th of may because
all these uh let's say uh activities are
leading uh towards uh monday uh where uh
on 9th of may we are commemorating uh
the schumann declaration which uh
basically uh um
represented an ambitious uh plan uh for
a long lasting piece uh
in
uh europe which is considered as the
the beginning of the european union and
uh if uh let's say 12 weeks ago
this may looks a little bit
outdated i think that nowadays
working for peace is
[Music]
continues to be a very important
part and
for us all and for the european
commission in particular
i could also add a couple of maybe
practical things if ever you think about
coming to work with us and taking part
in a competition for instance
um
make sure your language skills are are
well you know because we will test you
in two languages two european languages
and also go and have a look at our
sample tests on our website
you can find different examples of all
these different tests you have to sit
have a look at them train them a bit
because the more you rehearse and train
this the better you get at it and the
better you will perform at the the right
time when you sit these tests
thank you so much thank you zonitza
thank you [ __ ] and a big thank you to
our viewers this morning
thank you for your attention and we
really hope that you will stay in touch
with us please follow us on social media
you can see eu careers we are all over
we are on twitter instagram youtube
facebook
i think i named them all linkedin very
importantly this is this is where you
learned about this um event probably
today
so we hope to um to keep in touch with
you and we also hope that we will see
you very soon in in brussels or
somewhere else in europe in real life
thank you so
much thank you and don't be shy apply
bye